hey I'm Dan Perrault and these are the
10 best trailers of 2015 number 10
train wreck this trailer introduces us
to Amy and her ridiculous yet relatable
modern age dating problems but we also
learned that LeBron James and John Cena
aren't just super athletic they're also
hilarious which is unfair number 9 the
good dinosaur cute characters funny
moments plenty of adventure it's the
perfect recipe for a classic Pixar
trailer oh and it makes you cry number 8
crimson peak everything about the
crimson peak trailer is creepy the house
the bloody snow the skeleton the butcher
knife Tom Hiddleston's face you have to
trust me
number seven Spectre Vaughn movies are
perfect for trailers awesome cars
beautiful women lots of action and the
other kind of action but the Spectre
trailer effectively replaced action with
eerie cryptic hints of James Bond's past
number six creep this isn't rocky 7 it's
two partners literally fighting for
their lives and that's exactly what this
Creed preview teaches us full of action
drama and chickens this trailer might
take the prize for biggest adrenaline
rush who's next
number five Straight Outta Compton
starting with a one-minute intro by dr.
Dre and Ice Cube this trailer shows us
that the story behind Straight Outta
Compton is as relevant now as ever it's
gritty honest and features the kind of
crazy parties I wish I was invited to
number four the Martian this did a great
job of showing us the ups and downs of
our stranded astronaut without tipping
off the answer to the all-important
question does he survive number three
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
director Zack Snyder is known for his
epic trailers and Batman vs Superman is
probably his ethicist is that a word we
get the first glimpse of Lex Luthor and
Wonder Woman the first signs of Joker
and navy and aquaman tease zack snyder
take all my money now all $250 of it
number 2 Mad Max fury road the trailer 2
fury road was one trippy visually mind
effing experience I didn't always know
what I was watching but it was
incredible all the way through and then
I saw the movie and I still didn't know
what I was watching
and now the winner for best trailer of
2015 envelope leads it's Star Wars
the final Star Wars trailer gave us so
much kylo ren's voice more Han Solo
awesome aerial battles all while keeping
alive the important questions like
where's Luke Skywalker and how does
Harrison Ford still look that good
Chewie that right there is trailer
perfection thank you for watching and be
sure to check out more trailers in 2016
on Fandango movie clips let's check out
what actually did when it was Star Wars
right oh it's Joe Dirt 2